un ballet incessant presque ininterrompu
de poids lourds depuis lundi les camions
envahissent les rues de brienon pour le
maire s'en est trop il leur interdit
bien arrêter de passer par le
centre-ville de sa commune on l'a
constaté depuis quelques minutes de
présence il est passé au moins une
vingtaine de poids-lourds en même pas
dix minutes on peut pas tolérer de
laisser notre ville de voir son centre
ville dégradé détruits
de belle façon cette hausse du trafic
des camions a une explication
le chantier de la nationale 77 à une
dizaine de kilomètres à saint florentin
cette route très fréquentée qui relie
auxerre à 3 est coupée pendant une
quinzaine de jours en raison de travaux
les poids lourds voire sur déviation une
déviation qui passe arguments sur
armançon les habitants excédés par les
nuisances se félicite de l'arrêté pris
par le maire on va là oui ça roule un
jour d'hui ça fait vivre et les parcs et
ça fait vibrer les fenêtres et une en
centre-ville avec les commerces pour les
commerçants les gens qui vont faire leur
petit d'achat c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident avec plein de poids lourds et
relais s'arrête pas le problème n'est
pas nouveau et dure depuis des années et
le maire a sa solution
le contournement de brienon le véritable
sujet c'est la déviation du centre les
camions ne s'arrête pas ils ne peuvent
pas s'arrêter
un camion qui s'arrêtent créé un bouchon
donc il passe nous avons des centaines
de camions
il passe il ya déjà eu une personne
d'écraser ya quelques années un
contournement de brienon qui a un coût
le chantier est estimé à 2 ou 3 millions
d'euros une somme que le conseil
départemental ne semble pour l'heure
avoir en guerre